joe biden has nominated a man called
david
chipman to lead the atf the bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms
this is a concern for a number of
reasons the first is that david chipman
is
a zealot such a zealot that he has
repeatedly shown himself to be willing
to
lie in the service of his ideology
in a recent internet post for example
david chipman claimed that the branch
davidians in waco back in 1993
shot down federal helicopters during the
siege that year and that's not true they
didn't
david shipman should have known that
wasn't true he was directly involved in
the siege
today during his confirmation hearings
in the congress david shipman once again
failed to tell the truth he testified
that to keep this country safe gun
owners of the ar-15 should be arrested
with respect to the ar-15 on i support
a ban as as has been presented
in a senate bill and supported by the
president
um the ar-15 is a gun i was issued on
atf's
swat team and it's a particularly lethal
weapon
um and regulating it as other
particularly lethal weapons
i have advocated for as
atf director if i'm confirmed i would
simply enforce the laws on the books
so much about that was false the ar-15
is one of in fact the
less lethal rifles you can buy in a gun
store
you wouldn't take it deer hunting
because it's not lethal enough most of
the time
but it's also evidence of zealotry and
that's we want to speak to jesse kelly
tonight he's the host of the jesse kelly
show
to assess this so jesse how many i mean
just roughly speaking
there are more than dozens of ar-15s in
circulation i think there are
tens of millions of them likely what
would it mean
to ban them in in real terms
it would mean we would get the world
that david shipman wants and that's the
world where he's free to hurt you
tucker hurt me hurt anybody who
disagrees with him i i don't know why we
feel the need to dance around this
because
this is what the mistake we make on the
right we hear
ar-15 band and we hold up some chart
that says well pistols and fists and
stuff
they hurt more people every year these
people know that david chipman can read
he's an idiot but he can read he knows
that
what he wants is the freedom to hurt you
and i don't know why we have to dance
around that
it's such a smart point why does nobody
say that
well nobody says it because it means
acknowledging your fellow americans want
you dead or at least
are okay if you are dead and i realize
that sounds extreme
people they've called you a nazi for
four years for a reason
that's what they think you are do you
think david chipman thinks
nazis should be able to own ar-15s no he
wants the
the ability he wants the authority to
ban them i mean putting that guy
in charge of the atf it's like throwing
a party for your friends and letting
bill cosby tend the bar
it's i mean to target a firearm that is
owned
overwhelmingly by the most law-abiding
people
in the country i read a story the other
day that said that people with a
concealed weapons permit
are less likely than police officers to
commit crimes they commit no crimes
and that that goes for the overwhelming
majority of ar-15 owners to target them
tells you that it's not really about
reducing violence is it
oh no it's not about reducing violence
one not real violence i mean none of
these people care about mass shootings
tucker they don't care about
inner city violence what they care about
is that they've never been able to
achieve their final socialist dream in
america because half the country owns a
lot of firearms that's just the truth
that was step one for every other
scumbag dictator in history
and our left in this country missed that
step and it's the only thing separating
them from pole pog
bracing to hear someone tell the truth
thank you for doing it jesse kelly good
to see you
you bet you too bud hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else